sometimes the real thing is just as
impressive as to legend the black mamba
is one of Africa's most feared serpents
and it's all that and more its Africa's
longest venomous snake growing to a
length of 14 feet it's also the world's
fastest snake zipping along it up to 12
miles per hour its head is often
described as coffin-shaped
and for many in Africa this snake is
synonymous with death without antivenin
the black mambas neurotoxins can kill a
human in less than 15 minutes while its
main prey items include small animals
like rats Bush babies and birds its
lethal bite is famous enough that even
creatures several hundred times in size
stay out of its way the Mamba hunts by
day it's not afraid to show the black
interior of its mouth and scare the
daylights out of this herd
it does this to avoid being trampled
Paulin wants to do here is clear a path
and the strategy works perfectly
wouldn't you love to scare people like
that haha sure would make getting
through rush hour easier and for those
of you who've seen enough nature
documentaries you know what this means
bush squirrel versus mama
squirrels are one of the black mambas
favorite meals and it gets worse the
squirrel has a nest of young nearby and
the Mamba is just as cozy in a tree as
on the ground the Mamba uses sight and
scent to seek out its prey it has the
squirrel and its nest zeroed in the
mother stays away but as for saving her
babies there's not a single thing she
can do but we can do something we can
avoid the obligatory deadly mama chomps
cute baby squirrel shot let's cut right
to the end of the meal just the last few
crunches I hope you appreciated our
discretion just be glad as a human
you'll probably never encounter one of
these elusive yet aggressive snakes
you